major terror attack rocked kabul
yesterday hastening the american
evacuation even further at least 12 u.s
servicemen were killed many afghans were
killed and joe biden just gave a blurred
speech blaming everyone
but
himself
the attack was perpetrated by isis k an
offshoot of the islamic state which is
apparently the sworn enemy of the
taliban which was the sworn enemy of the
afghan national army our allies at least
our allies until it ceased to exist
against the taliban which is now
apparently our ally against isis a
changing confusing infuriating situation
underscoring all the more how little we
have to gain from occupying that
god-forsaken country meanwhile the cop
who killed ashley babbitt defends his
shot the new york times claims
california republican gubernatorial
candidate larry elder only got into
college because of affirmative action
they're really heating up the attacks
and the biden harris approval rating
plummets i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from cool papa j magic
who says
if these immoral incompetents are our
betters then we are really screwed yes
this is this is the irony and i think
it's it's important for what we would
call conservative populism or trumpism
or whatever you want to call it
it's anti-elite
not because we don't think that there
can or even must be an elite not because
we don't think that some people are a
little smarter than others and
you know the best people should be
running the community
it's anti-elite because this elite
is
stupid arrogant
incompetent
and destroying our country it's it's
anti-this elite it's not anti-elite in
theory it's anti-disease they're
screwing up the the country notably the
economy in one way to to hedge against
inflation in a crazy economy
acre gold acre will let you
invest in physical gold
for as little as 30 bucks a month
michael you liar don't call me a liar
gold is more expensive michael calm down
calm down
acre figured it out for as little as 30
a month you subscribe you pay each month
once your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars they will discreetly
ship acre gold to your house they've got
a new hundred dollar a month
subscription to a five gram gold bar you
don't need to come out of pocket all at
once i have always enjoyed and done very
well investing in physical precious
metals i love investing in acre gold
specifically i got my bar sitting right
on my desk at home visit getting i
probably shouldn't have told you that
now someone's going to break into my
house visit
start investing in physical gold today
make sure you go to this url because
acre is giving away a gold bar to
qualify for the giveaway tweet or post
why you should be the recipient and
mention at get underscore acre that's
getacre gold.com knowles thank you acre
gold for supporting the show
i have been
more than fair to joe biden
for the record
compared i think to any other
conservative commentator pundit talk
show host politician
i have tried to be as charitable as i
possibly can be to him i don't think
that it's fair to blame him for
everything in afghanistan or even most
things in afghanistan i don't think it's
fair to blame him that there was any
chaos or violence in the withdrawal i
think some chaos and perhaps even some
violence were probably inevitable but
he has bungled this
as much as possible
every single step of the way to quote
barack obama don't underestimate how
much joe can f things up and he has and
then he finally addressed the nation
last night he was late to the address
and it was i
it was it was the worst presidential
speech i've ever seen in my lifetime
haven't been on this earth too long but
31 years been paying attention to
politics the whole time is the worst
i've ever seen it was slurred it was
lethargic it was meandering it was weak
it refused to take responsibility
just the open
just
listen to how he begins the speech
a tough day
this evening in kabul as you all know
terrorists
attacked
that we've been talking about worried
about
that the intelligence community
has assessed uh has undertaken
an attack by a group known as isis k
is he awake is he even awake here or is
he just talking that's what i sound like
when i talk in my sleep
uh
[Music]
it's
not a good way to start
it and it does matter i'm not just
taking a cheap shot at him when the
united states is attacked when u.s
servicemen are killed by terrorists in a
completely
avoidable and bungled
military operation
you need some energy from the
commander-in-chief you need some clarity
you need some force and he didn't bring
it
then he confused the whole issue by
referring to
the the distinction between the taliban
and isis and how did isis get back here
i thought we'd beat isis and what is the
taliban doing and what's the
relationship he left more questions than
answers
we've been made aware
by our intelligence community
that the isis k
an arch enemy the taliban
people who were freed when both those
prisons
were opened
has been planning a complex set of
attacks on the united states personnel
and others
first of all enough with the taliban
enough he calls them the taliban every
single time
only democrats do this the conservatives
refer to the taliban because we speak
english but but the democrats refer to
the taliban and pakistan and all these
other stupid and muslim not muslim
muslim because they want to sound
cultured or cosmopolitan
these are the sort of people who
probably go to italian restaurants and
instead of saying hey i'll have the
the spaghetti you know could you give me
a plate of the spaghetti they'll say oh
thank you i would have yes
no actually they don't do that they just
do it with certain words that are
non-western and and they think that this
makes them more serious and cultured it
does not
speak english get the point out there
taliban the taliban and isis and their
arch enemies and they the isis guys got
out when those prisons were opened up
who opened the prisons joe the taliban
opened the prisons the taliban opened
the prisons to free the taliban people
but then the isis people got out too so
are they arch enemies are they kind of
working together do they have a common
enemy in the united states all of the
above but now i guess we're told that
the taliban are our allies
which just proves the point
what the liberal imperialists who have
been pushing this endless war in
afghanistan have been telling us is that
look we've got to go there there's the
good guys there that that's the afghan
army it's the allies and there's the bad
guys that's the taliban we're fighting
them we've got to kill them all and then
then they'll have peace in afghanistan
and then yesterday we get attacked not
by the taliban but by isis that's
another group and isis is against the
taliban so now we've got to completely
switch and say no actually the taliban
they're our allies they're our friends
here the afghan army doesn't exist just
completely folded within hours so that
doesn't exist anymore now we're friends
with the taliban so what are we doing
what are we doing getting out is what
we're doing
joe biden meanders through this
ridiculous speech longer and longer i
won't subject you to it then he goes and
finally takes some questions from the
press
so is he taking a a rousing round of
combative questions for you know in real
time no
he actually you gotta gotta give him
credit for transparency he acknowledges
that the questions are pre-approved
ladies and gentlemen
he gave me a list here
the first person i was instructed to
call on was
kelly o'donnell of nbc
you have said leaving
afghanistan is in the national interest
of the united states
they gave me a list here
i have been instructed to call on
instructed by whom
who are they who tell you to do this
they
the people who instructed you to do this
are running the country you manifestly
are not
and you're not even competent enough to
hide the fact that all of this is a show
and it's all pre-approved
at least the first questions are
he then is asked
actually an excellent reporter here
uh it's hard to tell who these reporters
are because they've got their masks on
but
he he asks him about bagram he says hold
on
this is the question that my wife asked
the other day my wife who says i'm no
foreign policy expert okay i didn't go
to west point but
when you're leaving a country wouldn't
it be smart to get the civilians out
before the military leaves wouldn't that
be a smart idea i don't know maybe i'm
crazy
so this reporter asks that question
did you personally reject a
recommendation to hold or to recapture
bagram air force base
here's what i've done on the let's ask
to answer the last question first
on the tactical questions of how to
conduct
an evacuation or a war
i gather up
all the major military personnel
that are in afghanistan the commanders
as well as the pentagon
and i ask for their best military
judgment
what would be the most efficient way to
accomplish the mission
they concluded the military
that bagram
was not
much value added that it was much wiser
to focus on kabul
and so i followed that recommendation
was that i i actually couldn't tell was
that wegman i think it may have been
excellent question really excellent
question terrible answer but really good
question to ask him hold on was this
your decision are you the buck stops
with you is the are you the one who made
this call to abandon the air base before
before the air lift doesn't make sense
and what does biden do it's so pathetic
he blames his commanders
he says no they
they gave me the advice and so i did
what they wanted me to do it's their
fault
don't blame the buck stops with them
they're the president it's not my no
buddy your
your job is to get advice from a lot of
different people
and then either choose
whose advice you want to go with or come
up with a separate answer yourself
you're the decider whatever you want to
say about george bush i think george w
bush made a lot of mistakes and i think
a lot of the problems in afghanistan are
because of him and a lot of the
confusion in our foreign policies
because of him but
whatever you want to say about george
bush at least he was the decider at
least he owned his decisions and stood
by them
kind of proof that that sometimes a
wrong decision even can be better than
indecision
biden won't do that he's got to blame
everybody but
himself
peter ducey one of the last reporters
left in america reported for fox news he
gets up
asks biden
a question about responsibility
listen mr president you've been dancing
around and evading responsibility for
this whole
debacle
is this uh do you take responsibility
for any aspect of the collapse of
afghanistan you set a deadline you
pulled troops out you sent troops back
in
and now 12 marines are dead you said the
buck stops with you do you bear any
responsibility
for the way that things have unfolded in
the last two weeks i bear responsibility
for
fundamentally all that's happened
of late but here's the deal
you know
i wish you one day say these things you
know as well as i do
that a former president
made a deal with the taliban
that he would get all american forces
out of afghanistan by may 1.
in return the commitment was made and
that was a year before
in return he was given a commitment
that the taliban
would continue to attack
others but would not attack any american
forces
uh look fundamentally the the problem it
all comes back to me i'm responsible
but it was trump's fault this democrats
always do this they say i'm taking full
responsibility
but really we all know it was someone
else's fault so they're trying to get
credit for taking responsibility but
they evade responsibility entirely by
the way this raises a question a lot of
this debacle is because we've been we're
pushing down to the end of august or
maybe even
later if if the whole point was that
they were going to get the troops out by
early may why didn't they do that
if what biden is saying is yeah you know
a lot of the reason that this is so
violent there are attacks and everything
is because
we stayed longer and that's why the
taliban's not going to give us another
extension well why didn't you just get
out when when the united states said we
would then
wouldn't we have avoided this then
if you're saying that a lot of the
reason that the taliban had not been
attacking american troops is because of
trump's deal then why wouldn't you
continue with that
and then the worst moment of the press
conference then we can move on but the
worst moment of the press conference do
not let the left spin this they're
already spinning this as he was asked to
follow up by peter ducey and biden was
so defeated that he just put his head
down on his hands
because before
no no no wait a minute i'm asking you a
question
is that is that accurate the best
but mr president respectfully
that i don't think that the issue that
do you think that people have an issue
with
pulling out of afghanistan or just a
wave of things that happen
so pathetic he can't he can't even keep
his head up he can't even keep his eyes
open i mean he was struggling to do that
during the speech itself and now ducey
pushes back at all very simple question
and he puts his head down on his hands
the left is spinning this image this is
a devastating image for the biden
administration and the left is already
spinning it and saying that he was
praying for our troops that's not what
what happened you just heard the clip
he was not he was struggling and failing
to answer a simple question by a
reporter
earlier in the speech he said let's have
a moment of silence but he did that's
not what that image is from don't let
this had a blue check mark yesterday
tell me oh no michael how you're so
callous to make fun of this moment he's
praying for the fallen servicemen he's
not
he's praying that the reporter will stop
asking him tough questions and he's
praying that he can get an answer to it
but he can't because there is no answer
the chances that this guy gets reelected
are collapsing day and day after day
after day after day unless there's
widespread voter fraud in 2024. if he
even runs there's a headline from yahoo
yahoo news right now yahoo finance
odds slide for biden harris harris leads
trump by two percent
notice anything weird about that
headline
do i say anything
the odds slide for biden harris okay
that makes sense
harris leads trump by two so they're
assuming first of all
that trump is going to run
and that he's going to do very well
actually right
because it's neck and neck
and they're assuming that biden will not
run for re-election because nobody can
listen to that speech and think that
this guy is even
half sentient at this point he's not i
don't even just need to make fun of him
it's a tough job can you imagine
we all have tough jobs right i'm sure
you in whatever you do in your job i'm
sure
you're good you're a good listener to
the michael knowles show you've got your
priorities in order you probably work
very hard i bet you're tired at the end
of the day i'm tired at the end of the
day
we all are
and we're not running the world i guess
joe biden's not running the world either
it's a lot of stress and he just is not
living up to it the only person i've
ever seen not age in the presidency is
donald trump
it might have been all of the aspartame
from the diet coke or all the
preservatives from the fast food but the
guy looked the same
after the presidency as he did when he
got in and that's just not true it
wasn't true for obama was drew for bush
certainly isn't true for biden who
entered the presidency at 102 years old
and now seems to be 150.
really bad news for them because biden
ain't looking so hot and harris is is
profoundly unlikable
trump speaking of the shadow president
trump also gave a speech last night
take a listen as one nation america
mourns the loss of our brave and
brilliant american service members
in a savage and barbaric terrorist
attack in afghanistan
these noble american warriors laid down
their lives in the line of duty they
sacrificed themselves for the country
that they loved racing against time to
rescue their fellow citizens from harm's
way
they died as american heroes and our
nation will honor their memory forever i
want to express my deepest condolences
to the families of those we have lost
today all americans grieve alongside you
together we also pray that god will heal
the other courageous american service
members who were wounded in this heinous
attack
so he goes on and on and on in a
forceful energetic clear actually
concise way when i see he goes on and on
and on i'm not i don't mean he's droning
he's not everything he's saying here is
clear it serves a purpose and he's got
energy
this in itself is devastating people are
probably not going to show you this
video that he released because he's been
de-platformed by the liberal
establishment because they can't
tolerate that threat you know donald
trump he's so unpopular he lost by more
votes in american history and that's why
we can't ever let any of you hear from
him at all or ever let him appear on a
ballot again because of how unpopular he
is right right doesn't make a lot of
sense to me
that's what a president sounds like i'm
not saying trump is the only president i
think there are a lot of people who
could have given a speech last night i
think there are a lot of people who
could have actually handled the
withdrawal from kabul
biden could not
on top of this we found out the biden
administration apparently gave the
taliban a list of u.s citizens green
card holders and afghan allies this is
being reported today biden refused to
ducey asked him that question biden
refused
refused to give an answer now
perhaps that's because he doesn't know
what the answer is this is insanity the
argument for it is if you give the
taliban a list of the u.s citizens green
card holders and crucially afghan allies
in the region
then then the taliban will let them get
to the airport right
or that's sort of the rosy optimistic
view or
you just gave the taliban a kill list
what do you think it is knowing what you
know about the taliban which do you
think it is
criminal incompetence or
or
strategic this was a question that was
raised was this pure incompetence or
was it
subversion
or
was it sabotage or is the foreign policy
establishment trying to stay in
afghanistan i don't know i don't want to
ascribe to malice that which is equally
explained by stupidity but either this
is the most historically incompetent
withdrawal ever in u.s history or there
were competing interests going on by the
bureaucracy we were debating this last
night at backstage ben made the point
that
the people don't control foreign policy
the foreign policy is controlled by the
blob and has been for decades
which then raises the questions the blob
didn't want to leave afghanistan the
withdrawal has been so bunk we left an
army's worth of equipment there without
any explanation
is that
is that just the first step in going
back in it's a real question to answer
meanwhile we've got a lot of violence
going on here in the united states
we got a lot of national disintegration
here in the united states the cop who
killed ashley babbitt the trump
supporter from the capitol
he's speaking out for the first time
so this cop goes on nbc news
this is the cop who killed ashley
babbitt a trump supporter in the capitol
she went into an area she wasn't
supposed to and she gets shot and killed
we were told that the trump supporters
were violent terrible they were killing
cops that just none of that was true
none of that was true the new york times
in washington post had to admit it the
only person who was killed in the
political violence of that day was
ashley babbitt a trump supporter here is
the cops defense
i followed my training
and
i spent
countless years
and
preparing for such a moment you
ultimately hope that moment never occurs
but you prepare as best you can i know
that day i saved countless lives
i know members of congress as well as my
fellow officers and staff were in
jeopardy
and in serious danger
and
that's my job
i don't think he killed countless lives
regardless
that he saved countless lives i don't i
don't know about his claim about his
training and he did what he was supposed
to do and maybe it was a fair shot i
don't know i mean that an investigation
or a trial actually would determine that
but i don't think he saved countless
lives do you know why
because because no one was killed that
day except for ashley babbitt so you're
telling me of all the people that were
in the capital of all the people in all
the places the only one who was supposed
to deadly threat
was ashley babbitt she was going to kill
people
no one else not the horn guy not the
lectern guy not any of the other people
just ashley babbitt and that's why this
unarmed woman was shot to death by this
cop
and no one's asking questions
i'm not i'm not even saying the guy
should go to
jail it is certainly the case that if it
was a white cop killing a black woman
or a pro-trump cop killing a democrat
woman the guy would be in guantanamo bay
the guy would have had his life he would
have been doxxed his we would have heard
from him much sooner than this his
family would be threatened he would
certainly be in jail at least if not
executed
but it's a black cop
defending the democrats
killing a trump supporter so
totally fine there won't there won't be
a thorough investigation of this and
there should be
there certainly should be he references
his training speaking of training the
new york times is really descending to a
new low against larry elder you know
larry elder the libertarian
somewhat conservative candidate who's
doing very very well friend of ours and
doing very very well
running in the recall for california so
you remember l.a times called him the
black face of white supremacy then the
la times came out and said
because he cleaned his gun six years ago
that he's actually like a wife beater
he's a threat to america or something
like that now
new york times is upping the
the ante here
by calling him an affirmative action
case
that's the line
the the new york times rights quote
admitted to brown university under an
early affirmative action program mr
elder the second of three sons stayed
away from california for years moving to
the university of michigan law school
and becoming a lawyer and legal
recruiter in ohio
he's an affirmative action case he
wouldn't have gotten into brown
otherwise you see he only got in because
he was black so says the new york times
by that logic
every single black person
who gets admitted to any college in
america just about
is an affirmative action case
but they don't they don't refer to all
the other lawyers that way do they
you don't hear them refer to
forget even the lawyers anyone who gets
into any
college in the country nicole hannah
affirmative action case nicole hannah
jones
affirmative action case joy reid
affirmative action case maxine waters
no in fact we're told that you're a
horrible racist if you suggest that
black people get into college because of
affirmative action now we we know that
affirmative action gives an advantage to
black students
they don't need test scores that are as
high they don't need grades that are as
high as white students or asian students
so that seems unjust in and of itself
but we are told if you ever call a black
person an affirmative action case you're
a vicious vile racist unless you're the
new york times doing it against larry
elder in which case this completely
cheap shot larry elder's a very
intelligent guy i suspect he could have
gotten into a good school on his own but
clarence thomas made this point in his
memoir he said he clarence thomas one of
the greatest jurists in the country
extraordinarily intelligent guy he
graduated yale law school top law school
in the country and he had trouble
getting a job because people thought he
was affirmative action case and that's
one of the reasons he hates affirmative
action because he says i could have done
it on my own
new york times
using that
using their their own programs
which they say are compassionate using
it as a way to undermine this black guy
on the basis of his skin speaking of
black men who need no affirmative action
kanye west baby i haven't listened to
the album yet but he's got a new album
coming out it's called donda
and i i'm not maybe we'll do an analysis
of the album at some point he's got a
cool new gadget that he uses to to mix
the album that it's like a this very
innovative gadget that coincidentally a
friend of mine built
so that's cool in and of itself but what
i want to focus on here is
he had a listening party for this last
night and the central set piece
was a chapel with a big cross
and the action on stage he actually had
marilyn manson there kind of
representing the devil
his marilyn manson is a probably the
most famous satanist in the country
it was representing spiritual warfare
and i just thought amid all the crazy
madness that's going on right now
there is a little glimmer of hope
there's always a little glimmer of hope
even as the world decays which is that
the most famous popular musician in
the world
is an outspoken christian
and some people are saying that kanye's
just pretending to be a christian just
to be weird just to be eccentric just to
keep people guessing
i mentioned i have at least one mutual
friend with kanye west others as well
what they tell me is he's 100 serious
he's 100 sincere and that is a that is a
wonderful thing we can't even admit all
this craziness we can't lose sight of
genuinely inspiring
encouraging moments speaking of which
though i can't leave on that high note
we will get to the mailbag in a second
but i have to note this harvard harvard
university just hired a new chaplain you
know the chaplain is the pastor this
religious leader at a university in the
military wherever the prison
the new chaplain at harvard is an
atheist
they just hire this guy greg epstein is
a 44 year old writer of good without god
he is the new chaplain
he's going to coordinate the religious
life
of harvard
he
who is an atheist and a lot of people
are saying this is insane you know the
conservatives are saying this is insane
the liberals are saying it's very clever
it's so subversive it's so clever i
think it's just common sense i think
it's totally ordinary because
everybody's got to serve somebody
the the absence of religion what people
think is the absence of religion is a
religion of itself you can't help but
make certain ethical metaphysical claims
about the world and the official
religion of harvard is atheism and the
official religion of our country right
now is atheism by the way and so it
stands to reason that the chaplain of
harvard and
chaplain of other influential
institutions in america would be an
atheist too
he's a lapsed jew but he's now
that's gone he's just an atheist
not surprising at all that's that's the
most popular religion in america
as the legacy media continue to spin the
news
our newest podcast morning wire
continues topping the apple and spotify
charts we are continuing our commitment
to bringing you the news without a
hidden agenda so subscribe start
listening now to morning liar on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts leave a five-star review if you
like what you hear if you are looking
for an alternative to the legacy media
that actually values the truth the daily
wire readers pass is perfect for you
four bucks a month you'll unlock
exclusive access to editorial content
that you won't get anywhere else notably
stuff from me so right now i've got a
four week free trial when you sign up at
dailywire.com subscribe hurry the deal
won't last much longer we'll be right
back with the mailbag
welcome back to my favorite time of the
week the mailbag first question from
christina hi there hi christina my
husband and i were debating this morning
whether or not women should be allowed
to breastfeed in public without a cover
and wanted to know your opinion on the
subject he said it should be allowed it
shouldn't i'm sorry it should not be
allowed because it's public nudity and
it makes people uncomfortable and is not
necessary as you could use a cover or a
washroom
i say it should be allowed because while
there may be partial nudity it's not a
sexual act in any way and is necessary
for the baby and if it makes people
uncomfortable they can just look away
thanks we love the show
your husband's right
it's a simple answer because
your argument is that
yes men are attracted
to boobs
but
the act of breastfeeding is not a
particularly sexy act and it is not
presenting said boob in a sexual way
right
but the boob is still
sexually attractive to men
it doesn't your it doesn't change the
nature of the thing it's not as though
men are attracted to the female body
only in certain circumstances we find
the female body attractive in itself so
this is like sometimes you'll hear
people say
we don't need to teach women to be more
careful when they go out you know in a
dark alley late at night we just teach
need to teach men not to be sexual
predators it's like yeah sure that
that's a good idea but you also need to
teach people to be prudent and careful
like if we don't need to teach
we don't need to teach
people to bring an umbrella outside when
it rains we need to teach the sky not to
rain yeah no i yeah you people should
have an umbrella
and
yes you should be in you know you should
take note of the weather but
things are going to happen this is a
fallen world and there are going to be
i'm not saying all men are sexual
predators but there are going to be
predators not even sexual there are
going to be predators out trying to
steal your wallet they're going to be
people trying to steal your pocketbook
in a dark alley so you still need to
take caution when you go down the dark
alleyway and you are going to be
it is it is
a sort of sexual thing anytime any woman
takes any part of her top law in public
so i would just recommend those little
cover-ups they're fine i'm not saying
you need to wear a burqa just a little
cover up there i think it's good
obviously women should breastfeed their
kids but i don't think we should
tolerate public nudity uh because of
that we can we can take care of lots of
different aspects of society all at once
from max hi michael listening to your
argument for leaving afghanistan i'd
like to hear your response to a counter
you say because we have our problems at
home we should focus on those instead of
problems elsewhere but isn't that the
equivalent of arguing that because of
all the problems in the church today we
should not focus on evangelization and
spreading the faith to others what are
your thoughts on this counter thanks and
love the show dave's fault no i don't
think it's a fair comparison because
when we say evangelize we're saying
spread the good news of the gospel and
the church whatever her problems are and
there are many problems
the church still has the basic
truth of the gospel to evangelize right
i believe in god the father almighty
creator of heaven and earth and jesus
christ has only sent our lord who we
could recite the creed we know what the
good news is and so we can spread that
even if our bishops are jerks and even
if our episcopacy is falling apart and
even if sue from the parish council is
ruining things
we still have the message to spread when
it comes to america spreading her values
to the world what are the values
truth justice in the american way you're
not even allowed to say that in a
superman movie anymore you haven't for
15 years
what is the american value
the is it the pride flag
i i bet a lot of people would say that's
the american value we hang it up at our
embassies all over the world including
in the vatican
including in kabul
is that i
i don't feel that that represents me i
don't think i don't think trans pride or
something is is a value that i want to
spread but a lot of people believe
that's what it is we don't we don't know
what what
the values are to evangelize anymore
and so when i when i make this point on
afghanistan
i i'm not making a prescriptive argument
that we should and we we must get out of
afghanistan right now and it's the
eternally perpetually moral thing to
always be out of afghanistan i'm not
saying that
or out of meddling in other countries
affairs
i'm i'm making the descriptive
observation that we don't know what we
stand for anymore we don't know what
we're doing there that's why the people
want to get out and until we figure out
what it is that we stand for we are
simply not going to be able to project
power overseas
which is what happened in afghanistan
from alex hi michael please advise i've
been eating an apple a day and dr fauci
has not gone away am i buying the wrong
brand
what's with dem apples
thanks
i have nothing to add to that that was
really beautiful beautiful from camille
good morning michael camille hello i
recently was discussing dreams and lucid
dreaming with some friends a few of the
more hippie friends were saying that
dreams are premonitions a lot of the
time
and can reveal the true inner workings
of your psyche what are your thoughts on
dreams in general and lucid dreaming
thank you as always is this what dreams
are made of
well dreams can
tell you something about the world i uh
this happens in the bible this happens
through
mythology you see this in myths and we
probably some of us have experienced
this in our own lives
and whether that is because you're
getting a direct message from god
about what's going to happen or whether
it's because you're just
intuiting something about the world that
is then you're working it out in your
dreams in the same way that prophets are
not exactly people who predict the
future they're just people who preach
the truth because they can see the truth
in a world that doesn't
that can happen in dreams no question
about it but then you bring up lucid
dreaming lucid dreaming
probably everyone has had a lucid dream
at some point it's a dream where you can
control what you do
right it's a dream where like you
realize you're dreaming and you're like
oh cool i'm gonna fly oh cool now i'm
gonna fly or whatever you know uh
in
in those dreams i i think it's hard to
say that's a
premonition or something i mean because
you're controlling the
action so they can be kind of fun i
guess
if you want to fly or whatever but uh
but yeah i don't i wouldn't take too
much stock of that
probably those dreams will just tell you
more about yourself and your own desires
and what you would do when you think no
one is watching from matthew dear mr
knowledge i mean knowles after 20 years
of u.s and allied presence in
afghanistan how is it possible
that the taliban is still so well armed
guns ammo grenades etc in the u.s we
can't even get reasonably priced ammo
and biden's attack on the second
amendment is getting worse sincerely one
round shy of a clip
it's a good name
well right now the taliban is so well
armed because we gave them an army's
worth of stuff so it's true you can't
get atmo right now but
muhammad mahar muhammad al whatever you
know is
has all of your ammo that you paid for
with your tax dollars or actually that
your government just borrowed from china
to send over there and you're going to
pay the interest on the debt
i i think getting to the heart of your
question which is why have we not
completely wiped out
the taliban or why have we not
completely wiped out isis really the
only the only president who went hard to
completely destroy isis was was trump
and he did a very good job obviously
these little offshoots that keep
cropping up but but obama you'll
remember didn't
just try to totally kill isis and i
think the reason for that is we no
longer in this country try to win wars
we just try to manage conflicts
so i strongly suspect the foreign policy
establishment does not want to totally
wipe out isis and does not want to
totally wipe out the taliban and does
not want to totally wipe out any of
these groups they want to just kind of
keep a balance of power going on so that
they all keep sort of killing each other
and no one's ever in control and it's
always in a state of managed chaos
that that has been a
major aspect of american grand strategy
for decades now and i think the american
people are questioning that because we'd
prefer to win wars than just kind of
manage declines
but
there's a big gap between the people who
run our foreign policy and the american
people themselves from nick hey michael
me oh no nick
hey michael me again so my relationship
with my above average girlfriend fizzled
out and let's be real it's not me it's
her
now normally after a breakup i feel like
a phoenix rising from the ashes ready to
dive back into all the babes dms
however i've been thinking of trying
something new oh yeah you think rather
than the tried and true dating cycle of
swipe right spit game meet up talk sexy
get sexy and finally weeks later answer
this so what are we question
i was thinking of getting more serious
with a friend of mine who i've been
close with but never close with if you
know what i mean
do you think this is a better strategy
for finding a long-term ride-or-die bay
sincerely
by close i mean we never hooked up but
she totally wanted to
nick
you've written into this show many times
now
and i i actually think that your
colorful relationship life is
representative of many millennials and
gen zers
you need to get married nick you need to
marry
this girl
i strongly recommend marrying people who
you're friends with and who you like and
who you have shared experience with i
think that's a good idea i think it's
probably better than the swipe culture
but in your case nick
even if it's not this girl i think you
should walk outside
pick up a stick and throw it
and then the first
woman that it hits frankly the first
person that it hits at this point we
live in a brave new world marry that
person and then stop dating and stop
swiping
and i'm not saying stop writing into the
show because i do get a kick out of your
questions and i think they're
illuminating
but
you gotta
you gotta get your life in order nick
okay all right you millennials you've
got to get your life in order generally
from jacob dear michael i just moved to
a new city to go to college and i would
like to go to some bars and restaurants
to try to meet new people particularly
women however my extreme social anxiety
makes me terrified to go and talk to
people directly especially girls do you
have any tips for me to go over get over
my social anxiety and fear of rejection
thank you jacob yes i do i don't think
it's just you i think everyone feels
this way frankly i look i'm i'm a pretty
social guy
even if i showed up to a new city and
i'm i'm going to a restaurant or a bar
just to meet people to not just to sit
by myself and smoke a cigar and read a
book but to actually go meet people i
would be nervous too that's an
anxiety-inducing experience so what i
would recommend since you're starting
college is rather than just show up to a
bar and say hey ladies come on you know
hit me up i would recommend joining a
club i would recommend joining some kind
of activity extracurricular or
curricular and
meeting people that way in a little more
organic way and then sort of
hanging out a little bit and then so
you're in a more
structured environment and then that i
think would lead more to being able to
say hey you want to go get a drink hey
you want to get a cup of coffee now you
can just show up to a bar and get a
drink but i wouldn't
i wouldn't go there
just with the hope and expectation of
meeting women and picking up a woman
because you'll you'll be really nervous
you won't come across as confident you
might come across as overeager i just
don't think it's going to work
so i would do it in a little bit more of
an organic way and you don't even need
to go find the chickies first i mean
maybe you join a club maybe it's a
political club maybe it's a game sort of
club i don't know whatever it is
and just
just meet people and just hang out and
just keep it cool you know keep it cool
man keep it light
build up a little confidence that way
and then i think it'll happen more
naturally from daniel michael if
language doesn't matter anymore
and definitions used since the first
dictionaries are not properly used
anymore why are conservatives so worried
about being called racist homophobic
xenophobic or any of the phobes what if
we just treated them as children
these things are only as damaging as the
person being called them allows them to
be especially if they're founded in no
truth at all yeah i think it's true
i think there's a lot of truth to that
we should not uh worry about being
called
racist or whatever the left doesn't you
know don't don't be a jerk you know
don't don't hate people on the basis of
their skin
but knowing that you don't care what
what people
call you i it doesn't bother me i don't
try to prove to media matters or whoever
that i'm not a racist or what i just
don't care i mean it doesn't doesn't
interest me the fact is though it is the
worst thing you can be called in
american society today so it does still
carry power but i i do agree we should
try to rob him of that power one quick
question before we go from jessica
michael i'm a single 20-something woman
i've got both girl and guy friends
i don't try to be or act like a guy at
all but have always had a lot of guy
friends in addition to my girlfriends i
have sometimes been referred to as one
of the guys don't love that i never call
myself that however i'm still single i
wonder if being seen as one of the guys
that's inhibiting my dating life if so
what can i do without completely being
someone i'm not sincerely one of those
bros is not like the others yes this
will inhibit your dating life i'm sorry
maybe you do like hanging out with the
boys more than the girls but if you want
to no longer be seen in that way you
need to hang out with the girls a little
bit more i'm not saying ditch your guy
friends but
but you are a girl and you got to do
girl things with girls and that will
help you do girl things with guys i'm
michael noel's the michael knowles show
see you monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bora our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021 hey
everybody this is andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin